so so let me ask you maybe a different
kind of a question who does taliban fear
the most today
well perhaps the united states itself
because as of now uh they see united
states both as an ally as an oppressor
as well because uh you know
over the years the chemistry has
completely changed we've seen
uh
a time when of course taliban attacked
not just afghan people the afghan
government but also the united states as
well there were so many troops of the
you know united states that actually uh
fell to the bullets of the taliban in
different attacks we also saw situations
where the taliban actually infiltrated
into the afghan army and attacked not
just the afghan army but the united
states troops as well now i see this
argument time and again on uh you know
u.s television and of course the biden
administration has been backing this
argument that you know we trained three
lakh three hundred thousand of the
afghan soldiers and we gave them
ammunition we trained them we did
whatever we could and that's all we
could do
now did do they tell you that ninety
percent of these afghan troops
are actually illiterate
do they tell you that ninety percent of
these afghan troops do not have basic
education they do not know how to read
and write
do they tell you that they are only
trained in you know firing and
ammunition etc but they do not know they
cannot calibrate your strategy they
cannot defend themselves properly in a
proper strategic way
then how do you say that we have 300 000
you know afghan crews we have given them
humvees and latest you know gunships etc
it's not going to work it's certainly
not going to work
i completely understand your argument
when you say that you are not there for
governance you're not there for
elections you're not there for nation
building
but
once you entered
once you have said that you're going to
attack the al-qaeda this war is against
terror and there is this huge nato
resolute support uh you know group that
has come up you need to have an exit
strategy you need to have
support of the people there or the local
government while you leave
you cannot abandon them or make them
sitting ducks you know what happened in
iraq patrick the united states had to
return they had to return to fight the
isis many experts now say that here also
there is isis but in a very different
form isis here is called the isis
islamic state quran province yeah but
again this isis this iskp is not the
same as the isis of iraq uh or syria
this is very different the initial
fighters of the isis or the is kp in
afghanistan in 2014 1516 came from
pakistan
they were the disgruntled elements of
the haqqani network and the al-qaeda and
you know majority of the fighters were
from pakistan
so again and again there is one term
that you may also see uh you know which
is pakistan now many may say that i'm an
indian and you know i may go on a
rhetoric spree against pakistan but
there are facts there are books that
have been written there's research that
has happened not just that the
intelligence agencies and the
cooperation between cia mossad
rnaw in india
even if or that matter will reveal what
the reality is what's been happening in
seminaries or
what we call mother sauce in the
university of jihad in kpk
samuel who was a radical element there
and majority of the government of
taliban patrick which is in power right
now has come from the same seminary in
pakistan in kpk
so this is the reality of the day you
said what does taliban fear the most
right now i don't think they fear
anything they've achieved their goal and
in the days ahead in the months ahead
it's going to be
worse it's going to be worse for the
afghan people and that's why i see
people from various ideologies
you know people from different
ideologies in afghanistan are running
for shelter we do not want to only go to
us or india but anywhere but afghanistan
so if you like this sort of short club
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]